cloud computing is impacting all our
lives today from manufacturing to retail
agriculture and transportation it is
driving transformation everywhere
creating a connected world with
limitless possibilities businesses
around the world are looking for a new
kind of cloud computing professional
someone with not just the i.t skills
trained to think differently to adapt to
business challenges quickly and to
continuously innovate simplilearn is
proud to introduce the postgraduate
program in cloud computing in
collaboration with the california
institute of technology center for
technology and management education
hello i'm rick heffner program director
at the california institute of
technology
welcome to the postgraduate program in
cloud computing
offered by caltech's center for
technology and management education in
collaboration with simply
caltech is a world-renowned science and
engineering institute that marshals some
of the world's brightest minds and most
innovative tools to address fundamental
scientific questions and pressing
societal challenges
we've partnered with simply learning to
develop this high engagement program
a program that gives you a thorough
understanding of all aspects of azure
aws and google cloud environments
including
cloud providers selection application
migration
performance testing cloud workloads
identity access management auto scaling
and more
learn by doing delivered entirely online
in an environment that combines
self-paced e-learning and instructor-led
live virtual classrooms this program
will help you design build and deploy
cloud-based applications based on
real-world business cases perfect your
skills with hands-on labs and projects
with 24 7 learning support and ample
peer-to-peer interaction the program
also includes a comprehensive capstone
project to showcase your new skills to
current and future employers
the caltech cloud computing postgraduate
program
also includes master classes by caltech
instructors
benefit of their cloud technology
expertise as you build your new skill
sets in this fast growing field
upon graduation you will receive your
certificate of completion in an
exclusive online convocation event
you'll also be awarded 30 continuation
education units from caltech and
membership in the prestigious caltech
circle
entering this program is a great first
step in building your cloud computing
career
it will take dedicated time and study
but you'll be rewarded with one of the
most in demand skill sets that top
global companies are looking for
this caltech simple learn postgraduate
program fits into your budget and your
schedule you access all aspects of the
program from your own home or office and
the cost is a fraction of the tuition
and expenses of an equivalent on-campus
program to get started in this unique
program just complete our brief program
application and an admissions counselor
will walk you through the prerequisites
welcome to your future